i don't know if i'm the only one but if
there's a dog in a game
you've pretty much won me over that's
why in no particular order
we're checking out some of the very best
most goodest dogs in games
that deserve all the belly rubs and
praise
and if you're looking for even more
content to make your tail wag then
be sure to subscribe and slide on over
to our channel
come on zagrius is stronger than i could
ever be because if i had a cerberus at
home
i don't think i could leave without him
the giant
red three-headed dog may be guarding the
gates of hell
but he's still incredibly adorable and
always
always sue the salt of my failed runs
i also gave serb way more gifts than
were necessary but
i think we can all agree it was the
right thing to do
gta 5 is popular for many reasons
but you already know why it's here chop
the most loyal pup who rides shotgun
with me everywhere i go
being able to play fetch having his help
in certain missions
and even running around as chop are some
of my favorite things in gta 5
and easily grant him a spot on this list
my absolute favorite doggo guitarist kk
slider
based on animal crossing's very own
composer kazumitotaka
kk is known for his smooth tunes and
sharing the joy of music with the
townsfolk in
every iteration of animal crossing if
you haven't heard the live version of kk
house yet
be sure to request it the next time he's
playing at your island
parappa the rapper might be on a quest
for sonny funny's heart
but he definitely won mine long ago he
also showed me how little rhythm i truly
have but
the iconic paper thin pup is sure to
stir up your nostalgia
and make you want to play again from the
beanie and baggy jeans to reminding me
that i gotta believe
parappa is definitely a very good boy
[Music]
the mischievous sun goddess amaterasu
shines her light on this list
as she's one of the best canines when it
comes to both satisfying combat and
painting skills
okami is brimming with wonderful dogs
because we can never forget about the
kusa 5.
i love seeing the various breeds in
action and respect the fact that they
needed a good ol butt weapon to get
their motivation back
which ami happily provided
watching didi go from rough stray pup to
refined diamond dog
gets me a little bit sentimental but
that slow-mo shot of deedee
jumping into the chopper with snake for
the first time still
sends chills down my spine
the grizzly dog with his strikingly
familiar eye patch
is definitely one of the very best boys
who can 81 missions
help you scout out nearby items and
people and make you feel
really bad for being gone too long with
extra enthusiastic greetings
[Music]
curry mario from the presonus series is
a very intelligent albino shiba inu
outfitted with a custom evoker who loves
to go on walks and play at the shrine
for many players coromaru has a
confirmed spot on the team during battle
no matter the stats he's also based on
the real-life dog hachiko who remained
loyal to his owner even after they
passed away which makes me just want to
hug them both
so tightly right now manella's trusty
australian shepherd angelo has some of
the most
smile inducing limit breaks i've ever
seen
ranoa impulsively bought angelo from a
puppy store without telling her father
and the rest is history she fights
alongside renault and helps keep the
rest of the party in good shape while
she's at it
[Music]
it doesn't get much better than having a
dog accompany you
while helping you find goodies like gold
coins and power moons but
it does if they're wearing a hat
and when it comes to that very specific
criteria super mario odyssey
absolutely delivers the moon kingdom
really takes it to another level
by replacing the dog's hat with a space
helmet and giving him a chance to leave
gloriously in zero g
[Music]
literally the epitome of a good boy
boomerang's life goal
is to destroy all the bad guys after
they killed his family
boomer's revenge turns into your gain as
he helps you in and out of combat
can bring you back a gun from an enemy
he's taken out can tag nearby enemies
and require some good pets from time to
time
side note far cry 6 might be delayed but
my
undying love for chirizo is still very
much on time
[Music]
both dogme and river the characters
actor
deserve all the recognition they receive
dogmeat has been one of everyone's
favorite companions in the fallout
series by being a powerful aide in
combat
and river has even received an award for
top video game dog of 2015.
it's so wholesome to see how proud river
looks next to her trophy
[Music]
wall is the helpful doberman pinscher
from valiant hearts that solves puzzles
with you
and can be used as the ultimate
distraction against guards because
of course no one can resist a cute
little pupper
walt's powerful cuteness can even make
players avoid
certain bomb ridden areas to ensure his
safety
he has a doggo after all so sometimes he
can end up in a little danger chasing
after food
[Music]
the dog from fable 2 is as loyal as they
come
since they've stuck by your side since
you saved them from a bully
the dog helps the hero with various
things throughout the story like combat
and treasure
but if you equip your dog with a collar
you can view its opinion
of you but don't worry its love for you
will always be maxed
in the see the future dlc pack you could
even change the breed of your dog to be
a dalmatian
a bloodhound a husky or a mutt with
different variants to come later
based on the hero's good or evil
alignment
[Music]
while all of calico is filled with
amazing and magical cats
dogs and other animals i had to have a
corgi on this list
ranger is the adorable corgi from calico
and with the big small potion you can
shrink ranger or any animal
to a size where you can wear them on
your head while you complete quests
or make them grow to a size where you
can mount and ride them to travel
quickly and i can confirm ranger is
ridiculously cute in all sizes
[Music]
up next we got one of the beefiest boys
on the list
the mubari hound from dragon age is a
tough chunky companion who is ready to
square up against
any armored foes especially now that
he's imprinted on you
for saving his life in a side quest so
by saving a life
you've gained a friend for life as the
hound fights with you for the remainder
of the game
[Music]
dog from super mario odyssey isn't the
only mario dog worth mentioning
you might be thinking chain chomp but
we're throwing the recognition to good
ol poochie this time
poochie has been a yoshi ally for many
years starting with yoshi's island
kuchi is just a big ball of cute and if
you need proof then i'll just kindly
point you to
poochie and yoshi's woolly world
you're welcome all right spoiler alert
for anybody
who still has silent hill 2 on their
backlog a super secret
and specific ending can be unlocked that
is probably
one of the greatest ones of all time
after all the insanity and madness that
you go through
you are finally confronted with the
mastermind behind it all
ushiba inu it's hard to believe an
animal so
cute was behind something so terrifying
but
i prefer that over the alternatives
[Music]
if we're being real every single dog in
every game
falls in my personal best dog category
but if your favorite wasn't mentioned
then let us know in the comments below
and if this video made you happier than
a dog with two tails
then be sure to leave a like and come
back soon for even more
daily gaming content see ya
[Music]
you